hi I'm Andre kuznia rec I'm the
executive director of document and media
systems at Wolfram research and today
I'll be talking about notebooks and CDF
anything new that's going on there and
how we're adjusting some of our Terms of
Use every year I give a talk about where
things are going or where where they've
gotten to with our CDF format CDF
technology this year were it's changing
up a little bit I'll get to that my talk
but I'll start with going through
updates on what's happened throughout
the last year since the last conference
so we had released iOS Player which is
pretty exciting for us because it
completes our three-legged stool message
so to speak about our platform
deployment so covering desktop systems
the web you know server based cloud
systems and mobile devices the the story
around the iOS player is a slightly
different rule set of usage when it
comes to interacting with the content of
a CDF on the player or a notebook but it
mostly works out relatively
straightforwardly if you've already got
a cloud account with us so you use your
cloud login on the mobile device if CDF
files are being deployed from an
enterprise product they'll just be
interactive for people or you can do a
one-time in-app purchase on the player
on iOS device we got of course our 11:3
product release out in March and we've
been pretty good about getting our
player to follow that very quickly and
of course
you know our goal is that you know we'd
like to never have to say anything new
about the player it's like hey it's
perfect but you know there's always a
few little updates and tweaks and bug
fixes that need to be handled we did a a
redesign of the start up screen that has
for a little while now we've had the
player pro upgrade indicator on that
screen so you can yourself relicense the
player to be a player pro application
which regardless of what type of file
you're opening you can use it at the
highest level our you know our player
technology allows it's the same as
enterprise and you can also hide the
startup screen which for a lot of folks
is nice once they get it yes I'm using
player the file menus in our desktop
products were also modified and there's
more modification coming with version 12
but we had simplified things to a CDF
preview menu item and from the preview
you then have the option for exporting
to CDF and it's it's automatically tied
to whatever license level you're at so
the biggest story of course in the last
year and a half or so has been that the
web plugin that had always been part of
our player product and part of our all
of our desktop products simply isn't
supported by any browsers anymore yeah
it's just true for everybody's plugins
Adobe had been getting a pass for the
longest time but even that's going away
so it's just not a plug-in world anymore
and that's you know that's really
something that
makes our cloud efforts a priority and
you know we're always throwing the word
cloud around you know we shouldn't let
people be confused by by that term we
really just mean you know our technology
running on the web and usable by anybody
in webpages they create or in web files
that they share and that's an important
story for us it it allows for pretty
much anybody to have access to what we
offer with with no complications but
it's a pretty ambitious project on our
parts and you've been hearing that story
from Steven for the last couple years
about quite a bit of work involved in
making that play well but you know we've
been getting there so in the case of
oops yeah
here the note book archive that Steven
had mentioned we were expecting to be
able to deliver notebooks through our
cloud system for anybody to use any time
and hopefully operate relatively
smoothly so right now you know I'm
clicking on a thumbnail I'm rendering a
notebook and and here it is it's got a
few issues you know we're still in the
middle of of converting a lot of these
but the point being that we want these
things to render quickly much like using
static web page and then to always have
the option to get at using the notebook
in its entirety in an interactive way
through your own account or download it
to desktop these options are kind of
hidden right now in a corner little
feature but the point Stephen was making
at his keynote was really that we we
want to emphasize that that feature talk
disappeared to okay
so similarly we
demonstrations we've been running these
in the cloud and somewhat depends on our
connectivity I thought I'd tested this
just like Stephen thought he tested it
when he was trying to show it and now
again my particular Wi-Fi here is does
not seem to want to let me run this and
all I guess I can recommend is to try it
on your own don't really know why I'm
running into this problem but all of our
out here we go finally okay you know
these are all running with a preview and
then a download that follows ideally the
timing of the sequence is that the the
preview video is is overlaid on top of
the download process most of the time
that works cleanly again configuration
here is not my the best thing so you you
kind of witness the blue line and the
cloud object filling in but in the end
you've got something that you can
interact with directly I don't have a
plug-in I didn't download a player to
make this work and it can work for
everybody and of course straight from
the new options we offer here you can
get access to the source either you know
in your own cloud account or downloaded
to your desktop you can copy the the
actual manipulate object to your
clipboard and paste it into your desktop
product and otherwise we've done you
know a bit of a facelift on everything
that's here one other cool thing just by
you know putting everything together
through our cloud system that is really
like a server that's at your fingertips
hopefully without having to think about
it too much in the case of
demonstrations just because I'm talking
about them is having resource objects
through our resource system
at your fingertips so this should be
working right now at 11:00 three and
certainly with version 12 the the full
collection will be fleshed out but I
should be able to evaluate something as
simple as this but there we go the you
can see there's a warning here about
connection issues this is just the
string that is the title of the
demonstration and I'm just you know
using it as the argument to this
resource data function and that gives me
you know the manipulate object that is
stored under that title so you know
there's just I think we've got 10,000 of
these up and running we're just you know
getting down to the last thousand
besides the object itself you can
collect details about what's in it this
detail about the description includes
these key names that you know this is
all part of a string and that's the way
the string is produced or put together
in the object should we probably smooth
that out I think so you know having a
little key indicators would be nicer and
of course you can put the actual
notebook object there but I just want to
move forward let's talk about what's new
okay so the biggest story for us right
now is that notebooks are back as far as
we're concerned they've never really
gone away but the messaging from our
company the story that we've been trying
to tell about notebooks had been
something we really couldn't get out as
much as we liked years back and we
invented the concept of CDF because we
we knew that people at least understood
the idea of of working in a master
desktop product to create content and
then to push a button
to put it out into the world in a
portable form people understood that
from the paradigm established mostly by
Adobe with PDF and certainly using
products across the board that supported
PDF but particularly if you're using the
Adobe product to draw something or to
create a fancy document you always know
that you can produce a PDF that you can
give to anybody and anybody has the
player to look at it and use it so you
know we piggybacked on that idea and and
CDF rhymes with PDF computable document
format is exactly what is going on with
our technology so we we had a pretty
strong message with that and you know we
we thought we would try to trademarking
at the word notebook but we really
couldn't get there with it it's a little
too generic if you do a google search on
notebook you know certainly years back
what are you gonna find little spiral
feed notebooks that kids use in school
so it we just didn't feel like notebook
was a strong message or at least strong
enough for us but now it is and the
reason is because of this our patents
have expired on how our notebook
interface operates and that turned out
to be useful for the Jupiter group and
others like you know Google's Co calc
and our studio and then list goes on
where these technical suites are using a
document format that borrows a lot of
the conventions we've established and
calling them notebooks hey welcome to
the party you know so they're doing the
lifting for us we shouldn't ignore it
it's absurd if we were to walk away from
that
so we're embracing the notebook message
again and and certainly for us you know
we invented them so of course we should
reclaim a certain amount of
ownership of that message space so
strategically that what that means for
us is the the concept of free CDF is
something we're just going to dispense
with the player that we're going to be
putting out with version 12 is called
wolfram player it's not CDF player and
the idea is that any notebook you create
with any of our desktop products
Mathematica whatever is playable in the
player it it no longer requires the
magic number signing that we used to do
for CDF you know that was useful for us
because it it kept things separate from
what was going on with the straight
notebook we had a licensing terminology
associated with free CDF that I think
was somewhat confusing for people
perhaps a little off-putting that that
it was essentially focused on the share
alike concept what we were telling
people and it's a Creative Commons
license it's not like we were inventing
something outrageously new or different
but but what a told people was that you
put things out in free CDF you're
sharing it with the world in a way that
that you can't hang on to you're
abandoning your exclusive license rights
to it and you know okay you know it's
the trade-off that you make with this
free thing but it it sort of intersects
but not completely with the idea of
whether it's a commercial or
non-commercial usage we do find that
it's it's easier for people to grasp
that idea if you're selling something if
you're making something to sell it
that's you know that's a commercial use
and you should be talking to us but what
that means is we can we can now say that
go ahead just use your notebooks put
your notebooks out there if somebody's
got the wolfram player they can interact
with the notebook at the same level they
ever did as they did with free CDF
but if you're a publisher you know and
you're selling this to your students
okay you should be talking to us that's
just that's how our license is working
that said for all the folks here and I
see plenty of you that are our
enterprise level customers there's no
change
Enterprise CDF is still a thing CDF is
still the concept of I'm deploying
something out from our you know
Mathematica will from one rule from
desktop to you know my individual
customer base as an application you know
it isn't just you know a distribution of
the document I've been working with it's
it's an actual deployed application that
that remains part of our CDF message
that remains Enterprise CDF and you know
to be clear it was always a little bit
of a problem we had with the notion that
CDF was our deployment story notebooks
aren't just about deployment it's it's
one part of our over arching message
about how you work with our system and
you know the a person who is just doing
research is just trying to solve a
problem for themselves they're working
in a notebook and maybe that's all
they'll ever do you know they'll finish
their work they'll put it away they're
done it's not about oh I have to think
about am I going to convert this to
something so we really want to get back
to that notion of let people just share
what they've been working in if it comes
to the point where away I should you
know give this to Jerry you know so our
our CDF website which maybe you've all
visited in the past will get some
tweaking but it's you know our the story
we want to tell goes beyond our CDF
website now but that said you will see
this change on there where we're
speaking to you know what what is our
licensing about now for for what's going
on it's you're either dealing with
notebooks or you're dealing
enterprise CEF so in telling our
notebook story the current pages we have
you know our website I think was for a
while lacking in a good sort of homepage
of notebooks and so we developed that
over the last year you know I helped put
this page together that really nicely
talks about you know how our notebooks
work and similarly we've got a new what
we call a feature set page we've already
done a couple of these different sites
that really kind of explain our approach
to things particularly we did one for
machine learning we've got this one
coming for notebooks going forward so
this should be going live in a couple
weeks
a very nice page and you know by the
time you get to the bottom of it there
will be some another section here
pointing to all kinds of different
resources including any of the details
on what I've been talking about right
now so I'm going to leave that up as you
know this is where the the story will
continue to be told all right I have to
wrap up here so thank you
[Applause]